the instincts towards jealousy is so
strong and again has such an obvious
evolutionary origin to it if you're
putting loads of resources into raising
children that you've had with this woman
you want to know they're yours make
guarding is what the biologists call it
it's so common that I think it's
considered to be a human Universal there
are loads of sort of unwelcome phenomena
that come from that you know jealousy is
often the motive behind domestic
violence for instance the fact that it's
natural doesn't mean it's necessarily
good but it does also mean that trying
to completely override it is probably
not going to work like you have to find
a way of accommodating your instincts
you can't just try and suppress them and
try and like rewrite the human blueprint